this morning the fda and cdc announced  that out of an abundance of caution  we're recommending a pause in the use of  the johnson and johnson covet 19 vaccine  due to reports of six cases of a rare  and severe type of blood clot  following vaccine administration we're  recommending this cause while we work  together to fully understand these  events  and also so we can get information out  to health care providers and vaccine  recipients  right now i'd like to stress these  events appear to be extremely rare  however covet 19 vaccine safety  is a top priority for the federal  government and we take all reports of  adverse  events following vaccination very  seriously